هل يمكنني أن أقول شيئًا واحدًا لأنك أنت
لا تحبينك أنت وعضوة
الكونجرس مارجر تايلور جرين لا
تتفقان ولكنك أمام الكاميرا
تنتقد بشدة دونالد ترامب وقد
تسبب ذلك في مدير حملة ترامب  للادعاء
بأنك لن تكون مؤهلاً للانتخاب عندما يتم ذلك، تم إنشاؤها
بواسطة أحد معارضي الحملة الانتخابية
الذي قام بتقطيعها وتحريرها لإخراج
بيانات الثناء المجانية التي
قلتها عن الرئيس ترامب، إنه مقطع
فيديو تم تحريره بدرجة عالية قدمه أحد
نشطاء الحملة لصالحك  لم يقل
تلك الأشياء التي تظهر أمام
الكاميرا قائلاً أعني أنك أمام
الكاميرا إذا أخذت جملًا
وأخذت جزءًا من الجملة
وحصلت على نتيجة مختلفة أه من تلك
الجملة أو استنتاج مختلف من
تلك
الجملة  أريد من كل من
يشاهد أن يرى ما
قلته ولأنه تم تحريره
هناك لحظات حيث يقول
عضو الكونجرس بوب جيد أن هذا يشعرني
بذلك ولكن دعني ألعب لحظة من
ذلك حتى يتمكن الجميع من رؤية ما هو موجود
بالفعل على
الكاميرا.  قررت أن أعتقد أنك تعرف
ما
لا يمكنني الجلوس عليه ومشاهدته ثم أشعر بالأسف
لأننا رشحنا
ترامب، أنت أمام الكاميرا تقول هذه
الأشياء
جيدًا يا عضو الكونجرس ولكن هذا جزء
من جملة أكبر،
محادثة أكبر تم تحريرها وتم
حذفها  الجزء الذي أشيد فيه
بالرئيس ترامب وأخبره أنه
كان أعظم رئيس في
حياتي وأنني لا أنتقد
الرئيس ترامب أنا فقط أدعم
الحاكم ديسانتيس أه وأشرح
لشخص كان يسألني جيدًا متى
لماذا فعلت ذلك  أنت تتخذ قرار التأييد هذا
وأنا أشرح لهم ذلك
ولكني اعتقدت في ولايات ساحة المعركة
أن الحاكم سانتيس سيمنحنا
فرصة أفضل للفوز ومن الواضح أن هذا
القرار قد اتخذ من قبل الناخبين أه
أه الناخبون الجمهوريون في جميع أنحاء البلاد
يدعمون بأغلبية ساحقة
أنا والرئيس ترامب ندعم الرئيس ترامب
أيضًا، نعم حسنًا، أنت تقول أمام الكاميرا أنك
تعلم أنك لا تريد أن تقول هذه
الأشياء علنًا ولكنك تقولها
سرًا، ومن الجدير بالملاحظة أن نسمعك تقول
هناك على الرغم من أنك تعتقد أن الديسنتس
سيكونون أكثر  سياق ما قيل
هو أنني لا أنتقد الرئيس
ترامب علنًا إذا طلب مني شخص ما على
انفراد أن أجيب على سؤال
حول مقارنة قضية سأفعل
ذلك ولكن النقطة التي كنت أوضحها هي
أنني  أنا نيابة عن الرئيس، معذرة أيها المحافظ، هل
تعترف بأنك تقول
الأشياء بشكل مختلف علنًا عما تقوله
سرًا، وهذا ما
بدا عليه إجابتك يا عضو الكونجرس على الإطلاق ليس على الإطلاق
ولكن حسنًا